how big was the cosplay scene back then
when you started i don't i want to be
like um because the cosplay scene has
been around for a very long time i think
saying that like
i just happened to kind of come into it
and then i'm very lucky to be able to be
where i am because of it and yeah as a
cosplay i am a fan of cosplay yeah but i
would never say like oh cosplay is now a
thing because of like whatever but
because because of me yeah like that's i
think that's like the the complete
wrong way to look at yeah has always
been such a huge huge subculture of
comic con and everything like that
massively talented creators and people
putting their all into costumes and
everything um back then it was a lot
smaller i think with the pandemic and
everything popping off and everyone
accessibility to costumes and everything
it's popped off like [ __ ]
oh yeah i can imagine yeah yeah yeah but
like back then it was it was indeed
smaller well i i guess it makes sense
because back then just not even anime
but just like nerd culture in general
just wasn't as big as it is now so i
think i think cosplay the cosplay scene
has just grown with how the mainstream
has viewed this kind of culture yes
something like that so there's just like
a lot more there's a lot more people
doing it now yeah
do you feel like the barrier of entry is
still just as easy as it was before oh
honestly i i'm like there are there are
two wolves inside me because like i feel
like cosplays split off into
like the super hardcore like crafting
people who are like yeah you've been
around and like make their own stuff and
everything and then there's like this
super accessible all-inclusive [ __ ] that
is so good like when i look at cosplay
my mind goes costume play and i don't
like that like and the accessibility to
costumes has become
so amazing these past couple years and
to be able to see more people just be
able to like throw in a costume become
their favorite person in the world is
like
no that's pretty cool the coolest [ __ ]
ever i've noticed as well that like just
like even if you can't make your own
cosplays anymore just like buying
cosplays has become cheaper yes like
it's become because i remember there was
a point where like you would look up a
cosplay even in japan of like a school
uniform or something and it was like you
know two three hundred dollars plus yeah
now you can get a school uniform for
like as cheap as like you know 40 bucks
yeah have you seen the quality of the
like
you go to convention and you're like yo
that guy's wearing an akatsuki cloak yo
he's got [ __ ] on lockdown man that looks
so cool so how did you where did you get
that from yes i want that
there are times where i miss those days
because i'm like oh so like underground
and if like you saw a really really cold
costume like you like you had to have
made that you know yeah then again there
are two balvarines inside of me and that
is that there is accessibility now which
makes it so much better yeah 3d printing
right as i imagine that's been like a
big thing the 3d printing game is insane
i have some friends who literally have a
space like this and it's just lined with
walls of 3d printers wow mindy smalls
she has like like 10 3d printers and she
can be like oh you want a full cosplay
and she'll like print it out and she'll
like stop crazy it's so amazing
i didn't know i didn't know 3d printing
had gotten that good where you could
just kind of make like could you make a
whole costume which is 3d printing
absolutely yeah if you take the time to
like sculpt it and then like size it to
your body absolutely wow yeah it's
incredible game changer yeah so like how
long did it take you to like learn your
skills in cosplaying i guess because my
mom taught me actually your mom taught
me yeah because my mom my mom did hats
for the um like uh like uh what's what's
it called it's like the kentucky derby
but it's like in new zealand so it's
like the new zealand so it's like little
baby baby new zealand derby you know so
she'd make like those big hats and stuff
like that she won a couple competitions
and she did this thing in new zealand
called the
world of wearable arts
which is like if you're from new zealand
you know it's like this competition
where bunch of people and artists will
make like wearable things and send them
off to models to wear and then they do
like the cats it's really [ __ ] cool
so she she has a very creative streak to
her so does my dad like right um but she
taught me how to sew and like she helped
me with like my super super old school
dark magician girl from like way way
back in the day
god yeah it was so cool yeah oh my god
you saw you just had all the skill sets
just like pre-programmed
like mother i would like to pursue
cosplay teach me how to solve
all right well it's time to get a big
push-up bra and we'll contour the boobs
thank you mum oh my god well like some
of you like your most challenging early
cosplays to do then [ __ ] i like um it
kind of i was like how long did the
pikachu one take like [ __ ] four
i mean i was gonna say compared to some
of your laser cosplays that seems like a
very simple cosplay the wrong guy
um probably my syndragosa cosplay was
probably oh yeah yeah i uh me and my
friend zach designed it together and
then i i made it and it was like the
reason why it was so tough was because
there's so many [ __ ] scales and like
so many little bits and pieces and
everything that were just like yeah
stack and i was like this is just
how do you decide where you're going to
cosplay it seems like you kind of do
like all the stuff that you wouldn't
expect i love i have to love it yeah i
have to be the pyramid head i watched
the video where you made it oh that was
that was so cool i saw the change
pyramid head could tear me apart
roll me to the side of the church and
use my blood to create a mural of his
close intimate and personal relationship
and i would be thankful yeah i i think
my recent favorite one of yours was the
chainsaw man when you oh that was so fun
that's why we should do music because my
brother does music he did all the the
the music for that oh really ryan did
the guttural chainsaw
all sick yeah ryan did like full death
metal growl and everything like that oh
yeah you'd be really good at that little
growling i heard your death metal growl
the other day what are you doing well
you
so anyways do you want to see me
[Laughter]
for the part of scream
[Laughter]
[Music]
but speaking about voices you you did
the voice for super sonico as well
i completely forgot about that
holy [ __ ] how did it how did that come
around oh my god um so i did like some
work some cosplay work for sentai film
works
and uh they were super i [ __ ] loved
it they're so lovely yeah um they were
really nice and they were like hey we're
looking for an english voice actor do
you want to be the voice of super sonico
and i was like i'm not a voice
i'm not a voice actor but okay
um
man voice acting is so hard
it is so did you have like zero voice
acting experience before zero i had like
i think i did a little bit of like
cinder fall for monty
i [ __ ] love you monty monty had so
much faith in me
um but uh that's like the only
experience that i had and then i did
super sonico
how was that
i haven't i haven't listened to it i
mean you sounded good
i think
i think i i don't know maybe it's
because maybe it's because when i
watched super sonico i knew it was you
yeah you were giving me that and i was
just like that's jessica you're always
going girl let's go okay so you're
looking at me like at like a proud
parent yeah like like like a friend had
just smelled something
like that that was the general consensus
i don't think
if i could redo it i would love to
because i feel like
these days i i would for what it was and
the skills that i had back then who's
the best it was what i could do you know
i think if i did it now it would be so
much better because i think you just
learn so much more as you get older yeah
there's like so many different ways to
like adjust your voice and your tone and
everything even with cinder fall you
listen to cinder in the first couple
seasons and then cinder now the change
is like so different oh yeah yeah yeah
like very quickly yeah like i wish i
wish i had like had what i i wish i
could do now what i do then this this
version of me back then everyone's gonna
start somewhere right exactly yeah
especially that was like one of your
first big roles in a big show yeah
magnets and then they yeah me back for
the video game too
and so i was just like are you sure
like yeah it works around the first time
yeah yeah yeah you'll be right like do
not get me wrong i am so
incredibly appreciative that i got to do
that like yeah yeah like what an insane
that's an opportunity not many people
care yeah especially for their first
role like oh my god did you deal with
any criticism at all from like people
being like oh my gosh she only got it
because she's popular sure yeah i i i
honestly i don't really look at too much
stuff yeah the real question is did you
give a [ __ ]
small idea like there's a there's a part
of me there are there are two organs
inside me and um
it's a [ __ ] weird t-shirt where it's
like there are two wolves inside of me
and it's one of them's like i'm in sigma
they look like i'm gay
yes
this is the best wall of fame it was
good it was good
same
um
what was i saying where did i go about
the voice acting oh uh i'm no with uh so
with like seeing criticisms like that i
usually like try to just
stay away from like looking at that kind
of stuff yeah yeah because i know that
it would just destroy me it i also it
also applies though with like numbers
and stuff like that right so i apply
that whole kind of mentality and blanket
to everything right pretty healthy
i think it has helped me really a lot
because uh i remember talking to phil
like way back in the day
and uh he he said something like that
and he was like you know just kind of
you know what goes up must come down
right so prepare yourself and i was like
oh okay so then if i just never kind of
know how big or small
then i won't be
like sad when it's no longer a thing you
know yeah i'm glad you took it that way
because it could have easily taken it as
well if i just never go down oh my god
well yeah like i do i do see that some
people because some people think it's
like that right yeah
even if you have a general upwards
trajectory there's always like months or
weeks whereas it goes down of course
you're like i'm falling off
and you have to have that like full
conversation with yourself is like no my
content's not who i am yeah you know and
you have to you have to have that real
like real real real therapy session do
you guys do therapy no voice
voice
do you exercise let's exercise our mind
i exercise okay okay exercise also
exercise
he doesn't exercise you need to get him
on it i don't physically
[Laughter]
which is exactly the same as physical i
know how to solve a rubik's cube and
that was pretty sick
i've never done therapy even if i wanted
to right let's say i wanted to get a
therapist in japan
yeah i've i've heard of some therapists
in japan that speak english and i've
heard horrible horrible things oh i
didn't even think of that yeah it's
really really hard to find i've done
therapy before and it's like since
moving to japan it's almost like
impossible to find like an in-person
therapist if you want to do it it's
probably got to be online and it's i do
wonder if that's a good option because
there was um a time where like i was
talking to someone online and it was
like it was so nice to talk about just
to get like validated in your feelings
and stuff like that just to get certain
things yeah it definitely is helpful but
i feel like you do lose a little bit
like not being there in person you know
there's there is body language that they
read because the online that it feels
like there is like a wall like like you
don't you don't really feel like you
talk to a person sometimes even though
you know there's a person on the other
side there's just especially when you're
talking about some really really
intimate things just like that extra
connection and the extra like human
connection can really help i feel also
you know you run the risk of like
pouring your heart out and then they'll
just be like oh sorry the connection
what did you say you know you don't want
that in a therapy session pov australian
internet
sorry i'm in australia uh what did you
say could you review that so i'm going
through a tunnel right now
sorry my wife's calling me give me a sec
yeah you don't want that yeah